ja ich wollte mich mal ausnahmsweise
nicht zu irgendwelchen sternchen
unterstrichen doppel punkten oder
ähnlichen mich hat irgendwie angefasst
dass in letzter zeit nur noch von
geflüchteten die rede ist überall sind
geflüchtet wir freunde der deutschen
sprache wissen ist ein partizip ein
perfekt partizip und wenn die geflüchtet
sind es ja nicht mehr da sind sie weg
sind die gerade geflüchtet aber das sind
sie ja nicht sondern was man meint sind
flüchtlinge und das schönste daran ist
die begründung da habe ich dann
verschiedene varianten gehört eine davon
war zum beispiel die endung in lingen
ist im deutschen immer mit seinen
negativen behaftet fiesling widerling
stimmt andererseits liebling oder
säugling ist im frühling eigentlich auch
ein schönes überhaupt das ist einfach
quatsch also irgendeine silber einen
eine
stimmungsvolle das ist unsinn und weil
das nur gerade so schön ist grassiert
dann diese partizip marotte auch noch
gerne überall sind überall mitarbeitende
studierende und sonstwie zu gange seien
de unterwegs nur um die
berufsbezeichnung zu vermeiden also die
teure und umfassende umwandlung des
studentenwerks in das studierendenwerk
hat im übrigen an der praxis der
studentenschaft überhaupt nichts
geändert die ungleiche verteilung zum
beispiel der geschlechter auf
verschiedene studienfächer hat sich
damit überhaupt nicht geändert die
wahrnehmung von studenten hat sich auch
nicht geändert es ist ein wunderschönes
teures wortspiel was aus überschriften
auf briefköpfen geändert hat alle müssen
es jetzt sonst sagen sie mal raus es ist
aber unsinn also keine macht den dosen
wir müssen nicht denjenigen durch
sprache überlassen die amt das geringste
sprachgefühl haben und am wenigsten
davon verstehen einfach reden und dann
ist gut erbas basieren greift schon mit
sorge mit so einfach selbst
ein bisschen anders denn die
geflüchteten abend nichts mit gender zu
tun flüchtling ist nicht nur ein
sammelbegriff für alle menschen die
geflüchtet sind oder nach deutschland
gekommen sind aus humanitären grund dass
vor allen dingen einen rechtsbegriff
absolut kein rechtsbegriff denn die
anerkennung der flüchtlingseigenschaft
die muss durch verwaltungsakt erfolgen
indem wir fein differenzieren liegen die
humanitären gründe asylrecht orient
flüchtlingskonvention tatsächlich vor
oder nicht deswegen ist das ein
sammelbegriff aber auch einen
rechtsbegriff den nimmt man jetzt weg
und nennt alle pauschal geflüchtete und
hat daher nicht mehr die differenzierung
zwischen humanitären schutz bedürfen ist
und keinen humanitären schutz bedürfen
ist also zuwanderung nach deutschland
aus anderen gründen im übrigen schüler
völlig recht ich
höre das mit großem vermögen zum
beispiel
aktivisten extremisten habe ich noch nie
getan dort gehört kommt aber immer
regelmäßige nachrichtensendungen ist
noch nicht lange her hr info habe ich
dann mit interesse gehört paderborn ist
vom tornado heimgesucht von hendrix
sprach mit anwohnern und
helfenden ja deswegen ist die eine
hälfte gesünder die andere hälfte aber
nicht das hauptargument ist ja
irgendwann setzt sich alle studieren in
einer dieser diese sprache wandelt er
sich durchsetzen das ist nicht falsch
das ist kein natürlicher sprachwandel
der in der bevölkerung entsteht sondern
dass ich sprach zwar von oben
aufoktroyiert wenn du das nicht machst
bist du politisch nicht korrekt und
diskriminiert du meinst stand hatte
molinaro hätten jetzt schon gezwungen
also zum beispiel auch an der
universität düsseldorf da muss man
sendern oder man muss vor eine erwähnen
dass man natürlich alle impliziert also
es wird schon bei studenten der druck
gemacht in den bachelor arbeiten auch
bei der form ist es so dass man ländern
oder ist wenigstens kennzeichen in
welchen gesprächs sohn wird so
gesprochen wie das von der uni empfohlen
wird ja warum schreiben wir nicht so wie
wir sprechen und das was uns da
angeboten wird mit doppel strich und und
ob das das kannst du doch nicht lesen
ich habe weiß auch manchmal nicht ob
schluckbeschwerden sind wenn jemand
spricht auch einmal fehlt da war so wie
lange muss ich eine pause machen nur
damit sich gerne aufregt ja ich schreibe
ja gerade noch scheint ein buch gerade
fertiggestellt dass so ein authentisches
buch sein aber geändert habe ich gesagt
dem vermerk jetzt müsst ihr euch
entscheiden
beides aber ich soll dann begründen
warum ich nicht general und die
überschrift heißt bevor sich jemand
aufregt
mit inschrift stöcke wenn welche
bezeichnung gas gästen wie wollen sie
denn eigentlich in talkshows eingeladen
wenn ich war letztens sehr erschrocken
als er mich als gäste einladen wollte
das habe ich dann auch nicht gemacht ja
also ich bin da ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen zwiegespalten also mir passiert
ist jetzt oft dass leute wenn es so
umzuändern geht mir dann schreiben na ja
das ist ja für euch ich frage mich immer
was heißt
und dann heißt das sowas naja ich
schwule lesben und transgender und es
soll es für euch an für mehr stärker
nachgefragt ich brauche das auch nicht
also ich sags über mich entweder julian
fm stoeckel oder herr stöcke insider
leute die mich gut kennen sagen ja es
ist die stöckel aber das hat eine ganz
andere bedeutung
erfinder der gleichnamigen schuhe
dann kommt die leute sagen wieso sagt
immer die stärke ja weil das ist ein
synonym von großen diven man hat früher
immer gesagt die dietrich die knef so
bin ich die stücke so und weil ich im
bermuda dreieck der lieben geboren bin
ich in meiner parallelstraße ist marlene
dietrich geboren und hier wird gelebt na
ja ist doch logisch die dietrich die
knef und die stöcke ich bin die letzte
und wenn ich dann quasi jetzt denn leute
mir sagen er ist für euch für euch für
euch da ich habe nicht danach gefragt
ich hab's doch nicht gewollt und zum
beispiel wenn ich moderiere egal
firmenevents oder irgendwelche in
irgendwelchen tv shows und dann fange
ich eine moderation sagt ja sehr geehrte
damen und herren herzlich willkommen
mein name ist laura sage ich ihnen
gender ich nicht aber ich kann es auch
gar nicht ich weiß überhaupt nicht wenn
ja wo richtig nicht mehr sagen das ist
ja viel weißraum einen e dann wird ja
welche wir werden die gruppen bei den
silberrang an wieder sagen es noch für
euch dann muss ich wieder sagen wir für
euch wer ist denn jetzt
nur weil ich eine quoten zu und her
nicht für alles herhalten ja also zu mir
kam heraus dass andere hersteller oder
dienstleister
dürfte nicht jeder vielleicht aber
also über mich ist es manchmal einfach
eigentlich zu viel und wenn ich jetzt
noch wenn ich eins noch ich weiß auch
manchmal gar nicht wie es richtig mache
ich weiß jetzt sehr geehrte damen herren
innen und außen oder welche sind innen
und außen und und wer ist jetzt da und
herr politikerinnen und kleinen ihn
hinstelle war wichtig für wen wird das
denn jetzt geht es
ja ich glaube es gibt einen harten kern
von ideologen die das vollständig
korrekt durchziehen wollen das irre
daran ist dass das ein sprachverständnis
etwa so wie das bibel verständnis der
zeugen jehovas also eine eine
wortwörtliche auslegung dementsprechend
wäre beispielsweise ein baby das ein
bäuerchen macht eine beleidigung für
kleine landwirte und das ist natürlich
unsinn nur dauert ein bisschen bis er
ankommt
also so funktioniert sprache gar nicht
wir wissen alle inzwischen also wenn man
augenblick auf dieser welt sind es gibt
männer und frauen dann gibt es noch
alles mögliche andere kein mensch hat
ein problem damit aber ist warum muss
jetzt alles in einem wort genannt werden
wenn man weiß dass es frauen und männer
gibt und alle anderen auch noch da kann
ich also an liebe bauern ein schöner tag
heute nein nein da habe ich jetzt alle
dient die ich nicht explizit genannt
habe sind jetzt beleidigt das ist
völliger unsinn das so funktioniert
sprache nicht wir haben immer
sammelbegriff ein fahrstuhl ist auch
kein rollendes möbel und und ab und
konnte die sind geprägt mit einem
sinngehalt der sich intuitiv erschließt
und dann kommen leute und sagen wenn du
aber das und jenes sohn nicht benannt
hast dann sind die nicht genannten
explodiert und du bist ein revanche ist
so ist das leben nicht und dass sich
diejenigen allerdings aber auch
penetrant dann in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung gerade in den medien
durchsetzen uns dass einbläuen wir
wollen das macht mich eigentlich extra
wütend ich mag nicht gern reglementiert
werden war petri kann das auch durch den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk dort
wird ja geht also eine welt ändert ja
auch während sie moderiert macht auch
die sprechblase also hat man das gefühl
dass der öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk
das auch sehr gerne möchte generell kann
man sagen je mehr stellen die sich für
öffentlich relevant halten und auch die
entsprechende durchsetzungskraft haben
ändert wird desto schwieriger wird es
für all diejenigen die ist nicht wollen
und wenn man das prinzip der politik
gehen dass der in tollet intolerant ist
sich am ende durchsetzt die intolerante
ist grob am ende immer gewinnt und eben
nicht die mehrheit nicht geändert dann
hat man begriffen warum
diese entwicklungen ja bislang
fortschreitet und nicht gestoppt wird
eigentlich wusste sich politik auf einen
ganz einfach nachzuvollziehenden
grundsatz zurückziehen nämlich die
wissenschaft die bemühen wir so gern
nicht mehr lauterbach den rollstuhl
hatten sondern alle möglichkeiten der
ständig machen aber was ganz anderes als
wenn wir das wirklich ernst nehmen dann
stände eins fest im englischen wird
unterschieden zwischen sex auf der einen
seite das biologische geschlecht
nachvollziehbar und gender das verstehen
wir in deutschland schon meist nicht
weil die meisten bürger natürlicherweise
sehr viel weniger englisch sprechen als
man so denkt aber wenn man das
konsequent anwendet dann haben wir ein
biologisches geschlecht das
nachvollziehbar ist und da gibt es
männer und frauen und dann gibt es aber
einen längeren sehr sehr jahres noch
viel kramer ja aber trotzdem ein kann
englische wunderbar nehmen um es
auseinanderzuhalten da gibt es die sehr
sehr kleine gruppe der intersexuellen
die in deutschland glaube ich gerade
meine dreistellige anzahl wenn überhaupt
erreichen für die ist das dritte
kreuzchen auf und am ende nur gemacht
worden das sind tatsächlich biologisch
die die nicht eindeutig zuordenbar sind
aber das sind auch die menschen die sich
gar nicht in die öffentlichkeit drängen
und das ist fakt und das andere ist
gefühl und wenn der staat anfängt sich
auf gefühle zwei haben glas hier in rand
sexuellen oder sollten wir nicht ja 60
geschlechter oder wie auch immer man
sich heute und morgen fühlen darf es
darf jeder mache wie er will damit habe
ich überhaupt kein problem aber erstens
ist das privat und geht weder den
nachbarn noch den staat noch irgendetwas
an wenn es mal mitteilen will das ist
einfach privatsache und zweitens hat der
staat regeln aufzulegen wenn er welche
überhaupt erfindet die auf
nachvollziehbaren grundsätzen basieren
und das kann nur wissenschaft sein und
es können nicht gefühl sein so wie man
so einen hass und empfindungen und liebe
nicht sanktionieren bestrafen oder
belohnen kann so kann man das auch nicht
mit dem gefühl
heute dass eine morgen habe ich sehr
sauer einigkeit war ja am tisch und ich
glaube jetzt bei dem thema von herrn
stücke wird hier wieder einig kein
verschulden den ultimativen argumente
tiefschlag im duden gibt es sogar die
spitzbuben was ich jetzt wieder so ein
widerspruch in sich halten muss die wut
der wassersprung unternehmen also der
fall war für mich immer ein männliches
himmel